so i have three different scenarios here
of a cell being immersed in a solution
and the cell is this magenta circle
that's the cellular membrane and then i
have the water molecules depicted by
these blue circles and then i have the
solute inside of the solution inside of
the water solution that we depict with
these yellow circles and i've clearly
exaggerated the size of the water
molecules and the solid the solute
particles relative to the size of the
cell but i did that so that we can
visualize what's actually going on now
we're going to assume that the cellular
membrane this phospholipid bilayer is
semi-permeable that it will allow water
molecules to pass in and out so a water
molecule could go from the inside to the
outside or from the outside to the
inside but we're going to assume that it
does not allow the passage of the solute
particle so that's why it's
semi-permeable it's permeable to certain
things or we could say selectively
permeable now what do we think is going
to happen
well the first thing that you might
observe is we have a lower concentration
of solute on the outside than we have on
the inside so in any given moment of
time you will have some water molecules
moving in just the right direction to go
from the outside to the inside
and you will also have some water
molecules that might be in just the
right place to go from the inside to the
outside
but what's more likely to happen and
what's going to happen more over a
certain period of time
well the water molecules that are on the
outside and we talk about this in the
osmosis video they're going to be less
obstructed by solid particles if they
happen to be if this one happens to be
moving in that direction well it's going
to be it's going to make its way to the
membrane and then maybe get through the
membrane while something maybe this
if this water molecule was moving in
this direction well gee it's going to be
obstructed now maybe this is bouncing
back and it's going to ricochet off of
it so the water molecules on the inside
are more obstructed they're less likely
to be able to
fully interact with the membrane or move
in the right direction they're being
obstructed by these solid particles so
even though you're going to have water
molecules going back and forth in a
given in a given period of time you have
a higher probability of more going in
than going out and so you're going to
have a net inflow
net
inflow
inflow
of
h2o of water molecules now a situation
like this where we're talking about a
cell and it's in a solution that has a
lower concentration of solute it's
important that we're talking about a
salute that is not permeable that is
that is not allowed to go through the
membrane the membrane is not permeable
to that solute we call this type of
situation this type of solution that the
cell is immersed in we call this a
hypotonic solution
hypotonic
hypotonic solution
and any time we're talking about
hypotonic or as we'll see isotonic and
hypertonic we're talking about relative
we're talking about relative
concentrations of solute that cannot get
through some type of that cannot get
through some type of a membrane and the
word hypo you might have seen it in
other things it's a prefix that means
less of something so in this case we
have a lower concentration of solute in
the solution than we have inside of the
cell and because of that you're going to
have osmosis you're going to have water
molecules going from the inside so
you're going to have water molecules
going from the outside i should say to
the inside and that's actually going to
put pressure on the cell the cell itself
might might expand or it could even if
there's enough pressure it might even it
might even explode
so now let's go to the next scenario in
this scenario we have roughly equal
concentrations of solute on the outside
and on the inside at least i tried to
draw them that way so in this situation
the probability of a water molecule in a
given period of time going from the
outside to the inside or from the inside
to the outside is going to be the same
and so you're not going to have any net
inflow or net outflow you're always
going to have water molecules going back
and forth but there's not going to be
any net inflow or outflow and so in this
situation so let's see let me write no
net
no
net
flow
and this type of solution where you have
the same concentration of solute in the
solution as you do inside the cell we
would call this an isotonic
this is an isotonic solution
isotonic solution
and the prefix iso
refers to things that are the same it
has the same concentration of solute and
so you have no net inflow so hypotonic
solution you have water molecules going
into the cell the cell expanding kind of
like a filling balloon isotonic solution
no net flow and of course you could
imagine in this last scenario i have a
higher concentration of solute on the
outside than i have on the inside and we
can guess what's going to happen so
first what would i call this well i have
more of something on the in the solution
so i would use the prefix hyper i have
more of it more hyper tonic this is a
hypertonic
solution and once again the water mole
the solute can't go
can't go across the membrane but the
water molecules can and you're going to
have water molecules going from the
outside
going from the outside to the inside and
from the inside to the outside but the
probability that the ones going from the
the ones on the inside are going to be
less obstructed to get go out than the
ones on the outside to go in and so
you're going to have a net outflow you
have a higher probability of things
going from the inside to the outside
than you do from things going from the
outside to the inside because they're
going to be more obstructed and so
they're going to be held back i guess in
different ways so in this situation
you're going to have you're going to
have to water escape the cell and the
cell actually might shrivel up the cell
since it's going to lose that pressure
from the water the cell itself might
shrivel up in some way and you can
actually see this in actual living
systems if you were to put a red blood
cell into a hypotonic solution the water
is going to rush into it and it's going
to look it's going to blow up it's going
to it's going to expand and so it's
going to look like a over inflated red
blood cell and an isotonic solution it's
going to look the way that we're used to
seeing a red blood cell actually having
kind of that little divot in in the in
the in the middle area while over here
it's all going to expand and then in the
hypertonic solution the water is going
to escape the red blood cell and then
you would actually see it kind of
shrivel up
shrivel up a little bit like this
because all of that water is
or we have a net outflow
of water molecules